друзі які я фантастичні слова почув
відповідальність треба кажуть треба
нести відповідальність за свої слова ну
по-перше шановний колего про
відповідальність А де відповідальність
за слова коли президент сказав що
трицятка буде до кінця війни Війна не
закінчилась тридцятка закінчилась де
відповідальність де мільярд дерев де
багато чого іншого що обіцялося і
говорилося де все це де корупція
прирівняна до державної зради і багато
чого наговорено Бо в нас така історія
щось говор Як водічка тече а далі Все її
попідзабули де відповідальність за це а
ще я почув тільки що фантастичну тезу
виявляється примусити і обмежити місцеве
самоврядування витратами на саме на
армію такий дати напрямок - це порушення
закону і конституції а забрати в них всі
гроші ні